well 10 years my best year
the most challenging year the most fun
year
um i'm not sure where you're gonna play
ups and downs guys being injured
still finding my way in this locker room
first thing i told this guy is thank you
for saving me
i appreciate it i appreciate every guy
in that locker room i appreciate it
paul for getting on my phone last year
at the end of the season when
it was time to buy with detroit thanks
for everything i've
experienced being here this city making
me feel home
his organization welcomed me my quirks
my strengths my weaknesses
i'm not here today without this team i'm
not still playing without this team
so
yeah i think i thank them you know for
everybody my heart just forever be a
special year
like i said it sucks that we didn't win
it but uh
yeah i ride with those guys those guys
roll with me all year and i ride with
those guys
and that's what makes this one tougher
makes this one extremely tough
to be the ones not
not getting to win ones uh at the end of
the season not the ones
hoisting trophy so you know i think that
group
that group revitalized me and they found
ways to push me to every day to
challenge me and
asked me to be better to encourage me to
be better um
they were just friends they became
family and uh
it's been a great van of brotherhood
that we build here this
has been an extremely special year
under these extreme difficult
circumstances that everybody's
been under with the pandemic of kobe the
last year and a half the way this team
has taken me in
the way this court group has welcomed me
the way that they've allowed me to leave
myself
i'm forever thankful for